-Good evening, everybody.
I'm Seth Meyers.
This is "Late Night."
We hope you're
doing well tonight.
And if you don't mind,
we are going to get to the news.
President Biden and
First Lady Dr. Jill Biden
made a surprise trip
to Delaware yesterday
to cast their votes
in the state's primaries.
Though for what it's worth,
Biden just voted
the same way he always does.
"Ah, simpler times."
President Biden today
toured the Detroit Auto Show.
And you're not
going to believe this.
He traded the presidential limo
for a '72 Chevelle straight up.
MyPillow C.E.O. Mike Lindell
said in an interview yesterday
that FBI agents
seized his cellphone at
a Hardee's drive-through
in Minnesota.
The FBI says they weren't tipped
off about his location.
They just assumed.
"Hey, they want us to get
Lindell's cellphone."
"Alright.
Hardee's drive-through?"
That's right -- MyPillow C.E.O.
Mike Lindell said
that FBI agents
seized his cellphone
at a Hardee's drive-through.
So not a great way
to start his job interview.
After the death of
Queen Elizabeth,
Britain's Prince William
reportedly inherited
a 685-year-old estate
worth $1 billion,
which I think makes him
a suspect.
President Biden said yesterday
during a celebration
at The White House
that his recently passed
Inflation Reduction Act
is a win for the middle class.
"Thanks," said the one guy
still in it.
That's right --
President Biden hosted
a celebration at
The White House yesterday.
They were originally going to
ask The Beach Boys,
but Biden said, "Let's get
someone the kids will like."
So, we -- Can we go back there?
What did I miss?
Go back. Yeah, okay.
One more card.
So, we missed the part
that James Taylor played at it.
And that's a detail we call
"key to the joke."
[ Cheers and applause ]
Now -- now,
halfway through the joke,
I realized the problem, guys.
But I also --
There was no way --
And I feel like
I'm pretty good on my feet.
There was no way
for me to fix it.
Here's how it would have looked
if I tried to fix it
the way I thought I would.
Alright, ready?
Wally, thank you.
That's right -- President Biden
hosted a celebration
at The White House yesterday,
and they were gonna --
James Taylor was there.
They were gonna originally --
And they asked James Taylor --
They were going to originally
ask The Beach Boys.
How you feeling, Wally?
-I'm not sure
that was my mistake.
-Okay.
Yeah. Yeah, that's true.
[ Cheers and applause ]
It's always been a gray area
where cue cards land...
-Yeah.
-...and your responsibility.
-Yeah, yeah.
[ Laughter ]
-During -- Well,
since he's wearing a mask,
let's edit him saying,
"Sorry, Seth."
During the event yesterday,
President Biden
wore aviator sunglasses.
Although, at this point,
it would be a big deal
if he wore any
other kind of sunglasses.
Yeah, see? Now, that's news.
Republican Senator
Lindsey Graham
introduced a bill yesterday
that would
ban abortions after 15 weeks
of pregnancy nationwide,
but just 'cause his
first pitch of banning sex
in general proved unpopular.
According to a new survey,
67% of Americans said that they
are vaccinated against polio,
while the other 33% texted,
"Mom, am I vaccinated
against polio?"
Ferrari yesterday
unveiled its first-ever
four-door vehicle, which will be
an S.U.V.-like sports car
with a 715-horsepower engine.
Perfect for taking your third
wife's kids to soccer practice.
And, finally,
NBC is set to premiere
a new show next month starring
the Harlem Globetrotters.
It's called
"Chicago Globetrotters."
[ Light laughter ]
[ Laughter ]
Let's see if Wally
got that card right.
Oh, well, I guess that wasn't
the problem, then.
That was a monologue, everybody.
[ Cheers and applause ]
Whoo! Off and running.